hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Constantine episode a video it's
the last one of the season so it's gonna
go and break it'll come back on january
9th for those asking about the schedule
it will air 2 episode 13 that'll be the
finale for season 1 that's actually the
same week that agent Carter premieres
although that premieres on Tuesday so
agent Carter and Constantine will start
at the same time I'll also be doing
videos for that I know a lot of you are
asking about possible season 2 is it
canceled is it not cancelled so I'll
totally talk about that after my top 5
moments but careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting
with top 5 moments here we go number 5
meet Anne Marie from the Newcastle crew
Anne Marie is totally someone from the
comics she also has a somewhat
antagonistic relationship with
Constantine but she shows up a lot as a
ghost like she's one of the many ghosts
that haunts Constantine on a regular
basis she gives a shout-out to the rest
of the crew which is kind of funny
because one of them was Gary Lester who
we know is dead Ritchie and Judith being
the other ones although I guess you can
consider Chazz part of that group too at
some point we will meet everyone it is
possible that the group the Newcastle
group could reconvene to help him in the
finale
whatever that conflict ends up being it
depends on how tight they want the arc
to be for this first season especially
if they're not going to get a season 2
if the show finds out ahead of time that
it's going to be canceled which
Constantine hasn't it hasn't been
cancelled it tries to wrap everything up
answer all the questions one of the
coolest things though is finding out
that anne-marie is actually the one that
got Constantine into the occult when he
was about 15 it seems like he may or may
not have lost his virginity to her even
though the sex they were talking about
where he kind of dict her over literally
at the Newcastle event was something
that happened much much later in their
life one of my favorite things about
introducing the anne-marie character
who's a lot of fun is that it humanizes
Constantine it makes him a little bit
more likeable because you get to see him
try to make up for past mistakes the
idea of just how closely he holds these
unpaid debts to all his friends I think
we'll end up seeing the same kind of
thing happened with the Zed character
just because she's been captured by the
resurrection crusade so Constantine will
naturally feel the obligation to help
her out - just like he's trying to help
out amory despite the fact that he ended
things with Amory on a very shaky note
number four sister flirtatious turns out
to be one of the following Sisters of
Eve this is actually pretty fun later in
the episode when we find out that sister
flirtatious
one of the demons are not necessarily
demons but a goddess of Hell the way
Constantine explains it it was a little
bit funny cuz it makes it sound like
Adam proposed to all these fallen
sisters and they turned him down like
they didn't want to get married to him
Eve was like his fallback option it
doesn't make him sound very appealing if
all those women turned him down so here
are all the names that they rattle off
these are the names of the sisters
lamashtu who was actually the character
in this episode lilith durga and namah'
Constantine calls her a glorified
vampire
she's stealing the babies to help the
Brujeria so presumably whatever
abilities they have whatever magical
abilities they have it's passed along
genetically which makes me wonder if
they're gonna try and tie the Brujeria
plot to the resurrection crusade plot
was then just because of her special
abilities I don't think they're the same
thing Zed isn't a dark warlock but
usually by the end of the season all the
plot lines tend to converge so rising
darkness
Zed Resurrection Crusade all probably
going to have several things in common
with each other by the end it didn't
come off quite as funny as I thought it
was intended but it was interesting the
idea that Constantine through lamashtu s
ex-boyfriend so to speak interface to
defeat her it was a nice sequence and
metaphorically it worked really nice
like it probably look really nice on the
page but I think the funniest joke was
when they were getting ready to offer
the sacrifice the glamoured chicken and
Constantine suggested he'd dress up and
drag to make the trade number three the
Brujeria are behind the rising darkness
so I asked Constantine explains it
there's something that predates modern
society like something all the way back
to the creation of the world God's
creation of the world Adam and Eve
Garden of Eden the threat being he does
not have the power or the ability to
fight them right now which is where I
think books of magic helmet of fate big
artifacts come in I'll be really
interested to see how they explain it
obviously he has to obtain knowledge or
some sort of ability before he can fight
them so for now I'm gonna think of the
Brujeria is the big bat this season the
people that he has to defeat they're the
ones that are trying to merge reality
with Hell so whether or not the Brujeria
are working with the first of the Fallen
they are the big bad not the first of
the Fallen number two zette is taken by
the resurrection crusade as predicted
this is in line with what her stories in
the comic books her father is the leader
of the resurrection crusade and wants to
use her to bring the new Messiah
I into the world her name is Mary in
real life so it kind of syncs up like
her father named her Mary thinking that
she would become the next Virgin Mary if
you want to find out how that storyline
went down in the comics I don't want to
post too many spoilers in the video but
if you have read the comics and you know
what happens to that just use spoiler
tags when you're talking about it it's
possible that they could do something
different from the comments they could
change her story from the comics a
little bit because I really do like
Angelica Celaya she said she was only
contracted for a certain number of
episodes that doesn't mean that they
won't re-up her for season two and
remember even if something really tragic
happens to an actor there's always ways
to bring them back just like on arrow
with the canary and Sara Lance like you
can still have the actor on the show
regardless of what happens to them
during present day even though the
resurrection crusade sounds like a
positive thing like wouldn't you want
Jesus to come back into the world it has
very sinister connotations I really like
the scenes where Zed started to have
visions when she was talking to that
male model I feel like the
cinematography has really come into its
own as the series has gone on that's one
of the strong points of the series both
Constantine and Gotham are shot really
beautifully and my number one moment
Anne Marie leaves Constantine to fight
the in volce the teaser for the next
episode doesn't leave a lot to the
imagination but it does provide an
interesting idea about where they might
take the series from here and it all
ties back to dark Constantine the one
that we saw in the first episode the
real question is is which demon does
Constantine invite into himself is it
gonna be Nergal is gonna be some other
random demon for those that haven't rid
of the comics Nergal is just one of the
big antagonists of the Hellblazer comics
like one of the bigger villains
there was a brief storyline where he did
occupy Constantine's body where he did
possess him so it's possible they could
be ripping that right out of the comics
and then the rest of the season
his personal arc will be trying to
excise that demon while he tries to save
Zed and fight the Brujeria so I am
really excited the way they've escalated
things the stakes are getting higher
there's more collateral damage and the
ratings went up quite a lot to this last
episode let me know that what was your
favorite moment from the episode and do
you think that the demon that
Constantine invokes into himself is
going to be like the big bad from the
comics the Nergal demon just to talk a
little bit about season 2 cancellation
not cancellation so it's guaranteed
through episode 13
if ratings continue to increase
I think that they will get a short
season to they'll get 10 to 13 episodes
I'm totally happy with that if they
don't get 22 episodes it's not a big
deal
Asian Carter for example is only going
to be doing a tepid z' and just for
comparison just a bench market against
all these other DC TV shows Gotham is
actually getting the highest ratings
right now it's significantly higher than
the flash which is significantly higher
than arrow but Constantine is actually
getting higher ratings than arrow so
arrow is technically the lowest rated
show right now even though it's ratings
are really good for what the CW
considers good ratings the real question
is is what does NBC consider successful
in terms of ratings on a late Friday
night Grimm gets ratings that are almost
on par with Gotham so it actually does
really well in this late-night friday
slot but constantine is so later than
the night then it's like the graveyard
shift
it's like where you banish a show when
you want it to go away so the fact that
it has continued to do so well I think
is a testament the show it's a good show
it's just in a very bad time slot so
what I'd really like to see is them just
bring it back for a 13-episode season -
I don't think we're gonna get any
official word on that until after all 13
episodes air overall I gave the episode
an A - I thought it was a great
character arc for Constantine very
humanizing awesome Annmarie character
who were gonna see in the next episode
so we're gonna get a big longer arc for
her hopefully she'll stay on the show a
little bit longer - because I just I
like the fact that they're building
their cast out I feel like that's been
one of the weaknesses so far is that it
hasn't really had time to build a strong
supporting cast it has a couple bigger
supporting characters but Chaz for
instance wasn't featured in a lot of the
previous episodes it'd be like on arrow
if we just didn't see Felicity for four
episodes it'd be weird and just in terms
of where the show is out right now most
shows like this most John Rizzo's don't
really find their audience till after
the first season it usually takes that
amount of time for the creative team to
get their heads around all these
characters like nobody starts the show
and immediately knows exactly what it
needs to be like there's always tweaking
that happens throughout the first and
second season so I think Constantine
could be an amazing show if it gets
season 2 season 3 the problem is is that
it deals with these really grandiose
ideas these really big spectacles but it
has to build to those and it just hasn't
had that much time yet so Swamp Thing
books of magic helmet of fate
although
things they can totally do that stuff
but they have to build to it you can't
just lead off with that stuff it's the
same thing with Gotham they didn't start
out at Arkham Asylum as awesome as that
would have been they built to it and now
that it's there it's gonna be that much
more fun my favorite performers in the
episode obviously anne-marie and Matt
Ryan is Constantine I always love
getting backstories on characters like
this and usually that is also something
that takes a couple seasons to get like
you might find yourself in the third
season of a show and still be learning
new things about characters overall
great episode I am a little bit worried
about what they're gonna do the Zed
character this season hopefully she'll
make it to season 2 if they get a season
2 I think the odds are good I think they
can do it just remind her again the
shows coming back January 9th I will be
doing agent Carter videos because that
comes back on the sixth like that same
week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything just as a point of interest
Swamp Thing is ending its run in the
comics it's next issue is gonna be the
last one for the storyline that they
have going right now so I might try to
do a Swamp Thing bonus video at some
time during the break so if you're in
your mobile phone or on a tablet there's
new links that you can click on up here
it's the same as the link is over here
but click here for last week's
Constantine video and click here to
learn about spider-man maybe going into
the Marvel verse maybe I say maybe so
thank you so much for watching
that's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you